[Фейк Путіна]
[Останнім часом Путін зустрічається
з лідерами інших країн на великій відстані]
[Навіть із своїми найближчими поплічниками
диктатор боїться сідати поруч]
[Але, напевно, його креативна команда
вирішила показати свого лідера ближче до народу —
за сумісним чаюванням із бортпровідницями]
[Але щось пішло не так.
Наприклад, рука, яка рухається крізь мікрофон]
[Або чайник, який віддзеркалює пустий стіл напроти]
[Путіна насправді не було у цій натхненній компанії,
а відео було записано на так названій «зеленці»]
[«Зеленка» або хромакей — це технологія суміщення
кількох відео в одному ролику]
[Він виглядає правдиво, але
дрібні деталі приховати дуже складно]
[Ми вирішили допомогти лідеру,
який вважає себе великим
і підклеїли до його ролику
трохи відео з України]
[російською] У цій операції беруть участь
тільки професійні військові:
[російською]
офіцери і контрактники.
Немає жодного призовника.
[російською]
І ми не плануємо це робити.
[російською] Зараз ми чуємо,
що необхідно закрити небо
[російською]
над територією України.
[російською] Зробити це неможливо
на самій території України,
[російською] можна тільки з територій
якихось сусідніх держав.
[російською]
Але будь-який рух у цьому напрямку
[російською] буде нами розглядатися
як участь у збройному конфлікті
[російською] тієї сторони, з території якої будуть
створюватися погрози для наших військових.
[російською] Ми в цю ж секунду будемо розглядати їх
як учасників воєнного конфлікту.
[російською] І вже все одно якими
там членами вони є.
[російською] Військовий стан вводиться в країні
у відповідності до закону
[російською] по наказу президента, і він повинен бути
підтверджений рішенням Ради Федерації
[російською]
у випадку зовнішньої агресії.
[російською] У тому числі у конкретних районах
проведення бойових дій.
[російською] Але у нас такої ситуації немає,
і я сподіваюсь — не буде.
[Не вірте фейкам російської пропаганди!]
Слава Україні!